university of washington professor gave
a lecture on the topic wednesday at
georgetown university in washington dc
it's about an hour and a half
[Music]
good evening
uh my name is charles king and on behalf
of the center for eurasian russian and
east european studies here at georgetown
university let me welcome you to uh this
evening's event
the talk tonight uh by professor daniel
chiro of the university of washington is
part of a three lecture series on east
european themes uh sponsored by the
center for eurasian russian and east
european studies
two weeks ago we welcomed the noted
author and journalist anatol levin of
the international institute for
strategic studies who spoke on nato
russia and the balkans
and last week we hosted a lecture by the
boston college historian larry wolf on
venice and dalmatia in the age of
enlightenment
and this week we are very pleased indeed
uh to welcome professor shiro to speak
on the theme of genocide and ethnic
cleansing in 20th century eastern europe
now first glance the topics in this
series might seem rather disparate
stretching from contemporary russia and
the balkans back to the 18th century
adriatic
and now as professor chiro calls it to
eastern europe's nightmarish 20th
century
but there is a single strand i think
running through each of the talks and
that is the attempt uh to think
comparatively about the history and
contemporary politics of eastern europe
and to bridge uh the often very
artificial divides between europe
central europe and eastern europe
the work of all of our speakers in fact
in various ways uh represents some of
the richest comparative research on
europe's east among british and american
scholars today and we have been uh
privileged here at uh georgetown uh to
host them
it's precisely this crossing of borders
if you will both in terms of geography
and of academic discipline that we also
seek to encourage
in teaching and research here in the
center for eurasian russian and east
european studies
you'll notice for example in our program
that we write eastern in eastern europe
with a small e which is uh perhaps just
one small indication of the ways in
which the borders and boundaries of the
past have now begun to fade
our speaker this evening is uh one of
this country's most widely cited
sociologists of central and eastern
europe as well as of ethnic politics in
general
dan chiro is currently professor of
international studies and sociology at
the henry m jackson school at the
university of washington
he's held positions previously at the
university of north carolina chapel hill
and is taught at the national taiwan
university northwestern university the
university of california san diego and
most recently at boaazici university in
istanbul
his major publications include social
change in the modern era
the origins of backwardness in eastern
europe modern tyrants
and most recently essential outsiders
chinese and jews in the modern
transformation of southeast asia and
central europe
the focus of his work has ranged from
romanian peasant uprisings to the
origins of balkan nationalism to the
rural economy of sudan to the
psychological roots of modern ethnic
conflict
professor shireau has also in addition
to his scholarly work been instrumental
in the professional development of east
european studies in the united states he
was founder and editor of the journal
east european politics and societies
which has become since 1986 the premier
scholarly journal in the area studies
field
in addition he may well be i think the
most acknowledged person in
the east european field for pick about
any major book on social and political
issues by east european specialists and
you'll find that the author probably
praises and thanks dan chiro somewhere
in the acknowledgments at the front
now the topic this evening is obviously
of considerable moment as we can see
both from news broadcast as well as from
the
size of the audience tonight
and there is no better person to speak
on these themes than our guest tonight
so please do join with me in welcoming
professor dan chereau to speak on
genocide and ethnic cleansing getting a
broader perspective on central and
eastern europe's nightmarish 20th
century dan
[Applause]
well after an introduction like that
when i came in i looked at the cover of
the
program
and i suppose it fits the title
i decided however
before coming here that i i wasn't just
going to tell you a lot of sad stories
there are a lot of sad stories to tell
as you all know
but i'd like to
try to be a little bit more comparative
and put this region in this region's
unfortunate between this 20th century
history in some sort of perspective
as a result of the yugoslav wars
but also because of other events
including
most notably the rondon
genocide in 1994
the study of genocide has flourished in
recent years
as i'm sure you know
the term itself was invented
after world war ii or at the very end
actually in 1944
and then used in international law
specifically to condemn and prevent any
repetition of the nazi extermination
campaigns
the term ethnic cleansing became popular
more recently it gained prominence in
the early 1990s
with reference to the yugoslav wars
but both of these terms can be used to
apply and be applied to many other
events
both before and since
genocide for example has been
appropriately used to describe
systematic campaigns of extermination
uh conducted by europeans against some
colonized peoples in africa the americas
and australia
one of the more extreme cases which has
only a tangential relationship
to eastern europe but it has some
actually
one of the most extreme cases and
perhaps the first example in the 20th
century
was
the genocide of the herrero people in
southwest africa
which is now namibia
which was at the time a german colony
very briefly what happened was that the
hero people who numbered about eighty
thousand in total men women children
everyone
rebelled against
the germans who were
rather nasty colonizers
and mistreated the population
imposed forced labor on them and they
defeated a small german military
establishment that was there and kaiser
wilhelm ii and the german imperial army
were greatly offended
ten thousand troops were sent this was
19 1904
germany had as you know the
best and most modern army in europe and
they sent their best
and they decreed a death sentence on the
gerardo people they killed a lot of them
and they drove the rest into the desert
and set up picket lines and prohibited
them from coming back
uh in a census that was taken in 1911
there were 15 000 herrera people out of
80 000 left in southwest africa and the
reason they were any left at all was
because there was a scandal in germany
when it finally got out
and the social democrats in the german
parliament made it stink
and eventually it was stopped but
too late
the general in command was personally
decorated by the kaiser
the term genocide's also been used
retroactively to describe the
deportations murders and deaths by
privation that were visited on the
armenians
by the ottoman government in 1915. again
that isn't directly in east central
europe
but
it was the ottoman empire which until
just before then had been a major balkan
power
and that's a very complex event
the ottoman empire
or the leaders of the ottoman empire
had had the experience of seeing muslims
expelled hamas from bulgaria after 1877
by the russians eager to create a
majority
christian bulgarian state and that
undoubtedly played somewhat of a role
in the panic that the ottoman
authorities felt when they saw uh an
armenian nationalist movement during
world war one collaborating with the
russians the russians were also
the enemy in world war one and from
their point of view
certainly not from the point of view of
the armenians or unbiased outside
observers but from the point of view of
the ottoman authorities they saw their
action which turned into a genocide as a
rational preemptive measure the number
of people who died has been estimated
anywhere from
800 000 to a million and a half there's
some numbers that are higher the turkish
government today claims it was much
lower but the much higher numbers are
probably unrealistic and the much lower
numbers are definitely completely
unrealistic
well starting at least with the
russo-turkish war of
1877-78 and going through the balkan
wars
and then through world war one
and the years of the new states and
boundaries after 1918 and then in a
terrible and intense and bloody way
during world war ii
and then again right after world war ii
and now once more in the late 20th
century the balkans have witnessed
ethnic conflicts that have resulted in
massive numbers of killings and
deportations
so that in a sense really the armenian
genocide is part of this sad balkan
story now central europe
that part of eastern europe that's north
of the balkans
and is catholic and protestant rather
than
orthodox or muslim has had an equally
sinister history
there were
ethno-nationalist
hatreds there
before world war one
though not many much before world war
one but they were there before world war
one but these only became really severe
after 1918
and
as you know
poland and czechoslovakia as well as
lithuania had major problems dealing
with their minorities mainly jews
ukrainians belarusians and germans
and these problems were substantially
solved only by the massive genocide of
the jews during world war ii and then by
the expulsion of germans from eastern
europe primarily from the czechs to
dayton land
and from parts of poland and also from
voyvodena the estimate of the number of
germans who died in 1945
during the forced expulsions
is somewhere around two to three million
which is pretty close to 20 to 25
percent of the affected german
population
i know the german record during the war
was hardly eximplary it was in fact
atrocious
but once again all germans were
victimized in these expulsions that
resulted in a lot of deaths
in this particular ethnic cleansing
women children the old whether they'd
been nazis or not people who had been
socialists and had fought against the
nazis they were germans and as germans
they were expelled there was no
distinction made of what kind of german
as for poland's eastern minorities
problem it was solved by putting eastern
poland into the soviet union
areas around hungary
where there remain
substantial hungarian minorities left
there after the shift in boundaries in
1918 and again
after 1945 continue even today to be a
source of
some ethnic tension
in romania in transylvania that is in
slovakia
and today in the news again
possibly in vojvodina in northern
yugoslavia
so the record of east central europe as
a whole whether you're talking about the
northern part
or or the balkan part in the south has
been pretty grim there have been very
few major ethnic conflicts that have
been peacefully resolved
to have been a few
and in those lands that are today free
of such conflicts or substantially free
of such conflict such as poland
or hungary
or the czech republic that can be
largely explained by the fact that their
ethnic cleansing
and their ethnic simplification was
finished by 1950
and in that sense the yugoslav wars
of the 1990s that continued to this day
might be seen as just
the completion of a process of ethnic
simplification or what the sociologist
rogers brubacher has called the great
unmixing of peoples that has
characterized the entire area for the
20th century
now before attempting any explanation of
what's happened and continues to happen
in this part of the world
i want to expand the comparison in two
ways
first i want to point out that the
region is in no sense unique those of us
who are specialists in this area and of
course today
newspapers
or the the news media in general
look at this area because that's where
the crisis is now they tend to see it as
unique
and that happens wherever there's this
kind of trouble every time it seems to
be unique
then to balance what could easily become
just another series of tragic tales
because i'm going to say a little bit
about some other parts of the world and
their tragic stories to tell in many
many other parts of the world i'd like
to broaden the comparison in another way
by showing the the variety of ethnic
conflicts that have taken place
in the world in the 20th century as a
matter of fact
there have been
many many
such conflicts
and few have resulted in genocides
rather few have produced even a large
number of deaths those are the most
dramatic
but of all of the
ethnic conflicts or possible ethnic
conflicts that have occurred
most have not resulted in such tragedies
and i'm going to put up a chart
i found out a few years ago that every
modern speaker has to use an overhead
actually that's not true anymore i
should have brought my computer and used
powerpoint
and what i want to do with this is
simply using a few examples obviously i
could have put in a lot more especially
as you go down
the first five categories you can have
more and more and more examples
but the reason i put that up
not that i'm going to talk about all of
these cases
but that
in fact of all of the
known potential ethnic conflicts a great
many i want to show
have resulted in levels of violence that
are below genocide including some very
serious wars such as what's going on
uh in eastern anatolia today between the
turks and the kurds or in east timor
indonesia
i put the yugoslav wars there because
compared to the cases on top
it's not clear that even slobodan
milosevic actually meant to kill every
single last
person in a certain ethnic category
getting rid of them is bad enough and
many have died and many died in the
second category but if you go down one
below you see other cases where there's
been
well serious conflict and people have
died
by the hundreds or even the thousands
but not by the tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands
and then conflicts
that have been serious
for example in the american south in the
20th century in which people died but in
which there wasn't outright warfare
going on to
conflicts that aren't really
so much conflicts uh as
awareness of ethnic tension with some
political implications but not not any
significant violence
and then by the way there's a missing
category there are lots of potential
ethnic conflicts that never existed
i mean
i was born in france and i never heard
of the burgundians having it in for the
french well back in this yeah
a while back a while back yeah uh but
but not not any time recently and if you
think of all the possible regional
religious and ethnic conflicts that
there could be there are thousands it's
really like going through a list of
potential nations veneris gelner did
that
in his little book and his excellent
wonderful little book on nationalism and
he he came up with a number he said well
there are 800 potential nations but
there may be several thousand
linguistic groups that might at some
time claim to be a nation
but only a few hundred of those uh have
ever made that claim
oh i'm sorry
i should talk into this
well it's one thing to point out
different levels of conflict and quite
another to try to understand why these
different levels exist
after all even looking at
the
very contemporary
conflicts
in
just eastern and central europe
uh hardly any observer of
say the contemporary hungarian romanian
tension in transylvania
expects that
to turn into massive ethnic cleansing or
genocide
at least not anytime soon
why not
well
well maybe because the hungarians aren't
in a position to try to secede and so
maybe the romanians aren't worried about
that
or perhaps it's because they're not
being encouraged to try to secede by the
hungarian state
the same is true of the turkish
population in bulgaria i cite these
examples because
there too there has been
serious tension and particularly in the
1980s during the last decade of
communist rule in bulgaria there were
what amounted to expulsions there were
killings
and there was quite a bit of violence
and today there doesn't
seem to be that much of an issue though
people are very aware
of what ethnicity they are
those of you who are specialists on
bulgaria recognize that i'm simplifying
that may be part of what's going on it
isn't just turks they're muslims they're
muslims who speak only bulgarian they're
turks they're people who speak turkish
who actually are not muslim but
in general
what was viewed as a potentially very
serious ethnic conflict in the 1980s is
not today a
terrible ethnic conflict
there remains a significant jewish
minority in hungary
and no one thinks that they're going to
be pogroms they're occasional
anti-semitic statements by some of the
right-wing parties
but no one foresees the kind of
catastrophe that has happened
earlier to the jewish population the
czechs in the slovaks split up
perfectly peacefully
there i think
unless it was from traffic accidents
there were no deaths
and perhaps these relatively nice
outcomes
that i just mentioned
are partly the result of the example of
yugoslavia which has shown everyone else
in the region what happens if you let
these things get out of hand
on the other hand
there were very few
knowledgeable people
in central and eastern europe in 1910
who foresaw what was coming in the rest
of the century
yes there was anti-semitism yes they
were tensions over borders yes they were
nationalist movements
but
to have predicted in 1910 what was going
to come
25 or 30 years later
it was just inconceivable that no one
seriously thought certainly no historian
who discussed the main politicians the
writings that we have from that period
in the memories of people who were
living at that time and were
knowledgeable about what's going on no
one really forced out what was going to
happen
so the thing about this chart is that
and the reason i put it up is that
clearly it's possible to move up and
down on the chart and that's what
some of the categories the two
categories down below are the
resolutions that can occur short of
ethnic cleansing or genocide but
genocide and ethnic cleansing may occur
and we don't really have a very good way
until after the fact of trying to
understand why sometimes the extreme
form of violence takes place
and at other times not now it's it's
perfectly clear to most scholars who've
studied this or any other region of the
world with numerous ethnic conflicts
that the popular explanation of violence
that it's just the legacy of many
centuries of hatred
doesn't hold much water
yes there have always been conflicts of
one kind or another
but for much of human history and
certainly within the great agrarian
civilizations that dominated the earth
for close to 5000 years
at least until the 19th and 20th
centuries including the habsburg empire
and the empire of the romanovs and the
ottoman empires
ethnicity was rarely a primary source of
conflict and warfare
we don't have to romanticize
the ottoman empire the habsburg empire
something which is quite in vogue these
days it's a new book about the ottoman
empire that
that was well reviewed
in the new york times the other day and
that is somewhat of a romanticized
version
and there's been a lot of stuff about
the habsburgs that's also somewhat
romanticized for a good reason because
compared to what happened later
at an earlier stage these empires seem
rather nice but even without romantic
evasions the fact is that the
nationalist historians of the 19th of
the late 19th
and for much of the 20th century who
come from these regions and have
demonized the ottomans and hopsborgs and
the romanovs as vicious ethnic
oppressors
they've largely fabricated their
histories and they missed the point of
what it was that held these empires
together
similarly the notion that serbs and
albanians or serbs and croats or
hungarians and romanians or for that
matter russians and poles
have been hereditary enemies for many
centuries whole people hating whole
other people
is patently nonsensical
ethnic allegiances
tended to be weak
in the past
and when dynasties fought each other
they didn't usually mobilize people on
ethnic grounds
in the 18th century and even well into
the 19th century there were plenty of
protestant germans and catholic poles
particularly in the nobility
who were loyal subjects and military
officers of the russian tsars
there are plenty of christian and
armenians and christian greeks who were
loyal
servants of the muslim ottoman state
and in all those empires there were
millions of peasants everywhere who
neither understood the language of their
immediate land-owning masters
nor thought that it particularly
mattered what language their masters
spoke because of the social distance
between them and because of the fact
that what their masters did was
exploit them and extract stuff from them
and one master was as bad as another
there are lots of stories to be told
about that some nostalgic
some
just anecdotes
one of my favorites is when finland
became a part of
the russian empire
in 1809 the tsar of russia alexander
first went to parvo which was then the
finnish capital
and addressed the finnish parliament
there was a separate parliament even
though it had been part of sweden before
they had their own
estate
a state's general so to speak and he
addressed them
of course the language of the parliament
was swedish and he told them that he and
they were lutherans majority of the
peasants were
finns and he told them he would respect
their liberties and their religion and
being the orthodox tsar of all the
russians he'd naturally address them in
french and no one thought that this was
objectionable a hundred years later this
scene in 1909 the scene simply couldn't
have happened there was a finnish
nationalist movement there was tension
between the fins and the swedes which
had not previously
been particularly evident and the tsar
of russia
at that time still spoke french
but
given russian policies toward its
non-russian-speaking areas he would have
made more of a point to appear as a
russian
there are lots there are hundreds
thousands of stories like that
so the question is what happened in the
20th century why is it that there have
been so many brutal ethnic conflicts and
terrible unmixings
in east central europe and elsewhere
there are two basic approaches that have
been taken to explain genocide and
genocide-like activities
categories one and going well into
category two here
uh and maybe even
category three clearly has some
potential for that even though the cases
i put up there haven't witnessed
outright genocides or ethnic cleansings
on the scale of what's happened in
yugoslavia or during world war ii
one is to look at the 20th century and
to see it as uniquely
destructive
the depersonalization of modern life
alienation the frustrations caused by
the breakup of community have been
blamed for nazism they've been blamed
for communism that way communism has to
be included
because even when the killing machines
of communist states did not kill
for ethnic reasons sometimes they did
but
often not
when they used the notion of class they
used it in a way that became very
similar to the notion of ethnicity that
is to say that whole categories of
people were condemned to death because
they were in or related to a hostile
class that was certainly the case with
the
massive killing of kulaks
in the 1930s when
somewhere between five and 10 million
people died shot brutalized starved to
death
deported under abysmal conditions to
labor camps where most of them died
even more fundamentally
going back to this explanation that
there's something about the 20th century
some say that the fascination with
science
and the attempt to engineer societies
are to blame for the century's worst
killings
so nazism
can be and has been blamed on
the pseudoscientific extrapolations from
darwin
and the whole notion of race that
developed
uh in the
latter part of the 19th century
uh marxist-class conflict theory can be
used to account for the mass murder
campaigns conducted by stalin by paul
pott by
there's a certain attraction to this
explanation and particularly when one
looks at germany because
whether in 1905 when they
virtually exterminated the herrero or in
1940 when they set out to exterminate
jews and gypsies
and a good number of slavs germany could
hardly be called primitive if there was
a modern nation it was germany
but there's the exact opposite
explanation of what's happened uh that
we hear all the time that genocidal acts
are barbaric that they're reversion to
some kind of primitive behavior the
killer ape instinct in us
and you hear this often on the on the
news for example um
or even from people who have
participated in this or been the subject
of this how could such a thing happen in
our century how could such a thing
happen in the late 20th century how
could such a thing happen in the middle
of the 20th century how could such a
thing happen in the early 20th century
in a modern nation surely this must be
some sort of reversion to the past
i have to say since i know quite a bit
about it and have been very interested
in it that that what was
the explanation of what happened in
rwanda in 1994 when as you know eight
hundred thousand people were killed in
about a hundred days which is actually a
rate of killing of about eight thousand
per day
which is better than what the nazis were
doing at the height of their killing
campaigns
and this was explained in the press and
by our officials as well primitive
tribalism
never mind that the tutsi and the hutu
don't really fit what we think of as
tribes the story is rather complicated
and i won't go into it
but the explanation is no more
satisfactory there than it is for what
happened in europe
and particularly since all of us here
know what happened in europe to say that
what happened in rwanda was in some
sense the reversion to primitive
tribalism means that the germans were a
primitive tribe in 1940 or in 1905
well perhaps they were but in that case
the explanation
that it's all primitive doesn't work
so is genocidal behavior uniquely modern
as sigmund bauman would have it or is it
barbarically anachronistic
well i think that it's neither
and i don't think that either one of
those explanations which are both very
current make all that much sense i think
that the genocidal impulse
is
neither
specifically modern nor an archaic
throwback
it's not even a manifestation of a
disease state of mind
and whether
people who explain this have explained
it as a modern phenomenon or as a
reversion to the past a very common
explanation
uh is that it's these this is all the
product of a bunch of sick minds
and i don't think it's that either i
think it's part of our normal psychology
to carry the potential for genocidal
action
genocide may be the extreme example of
ethnic conflict but it has its roots in
normal impulses
and i say that for several reasons first
of all
because
there are a lot of examples from the
past
not quite the same as what's happened in
the 20th century let me give you a few
quick examples the paradigmatic case
from anthropologies actually the dani of
the new guinea highlands who were
studied when they were still
a stone age people and there were lots
of stone age
peoples in a substantial area that had
been untouched
until
well they had no contact with the
outside at all until the 1930s they had
a little bit and then really almost none
until the 1950s
and so that anthropologists were able to
study what happened and they found in
these areas that there was endemic
warfare village against village that
typically resulted in very few deaths
but from time to time one village would
overrun another and kill
everybody
or kill all the men
and all of the older women and take just
the younger women
but sometimes kills absolutely everybody
anthropologists who have studied this
and other cases of extreme violence
among
similar people such as the yanomamo and
the amazon have attributed such
murderous episodes to ecological stress
that is to say overcrowding
and
when the overcrowding gets too bad then
the situation gets desperate then these
outbursts of mass killing occur mass on
their scale that is to say nothing like
what happened in the 20th century
we're talking about a few dozen people
being killed or most 100 but in their
terms it could be everyone in a village
now obviously ethnicity wasn't an issue
as such in those because neighbors were
killing neighbors and sometimes as with
the yamamoto it was within a village a
village would split and there would be
killings and either one group would flee
or else there would just be a lot of
deaths
in agrarian societies that is to say
those with states there was also a lot
of genocide
though typically it wasn't ethnic either
it occurred to punish certain enemies to
make examples of treacherous populations
or to empty territories in order to
replace unreliable populations with
allies
there are plenty of examples described
in for example thucydides in the
peloponnesian war for example the
extermination of all of the males
in melos in 416 bc and the selling of
all of the females dispersion selling
them as slaves the old testament the
bible is full of genocidal stories
there have been books written about that
it's uncomfortable to explain some of
these things in sunday school so they're
usually skipped over
both by jews and christians
but the bible is full of genocide
there's
just two examples the case of the
midianites and numbers and the
amalekites in samuel in the latter case
the lord ordered the destruction of
everyone every last man woman and child
in the case of the midianites he ordered
that only the men be killed he told
moses
only the men should be killed
including the little boys
and all of the females who
i only read this in english translation
all of the females except those who have
not known men and these you may keep for
yourselves the lord said to moses
and that's pretty close to a genocide
there are a lot of reasons a lot of
examples the romans the mongols the
aztecs crusading european knights
zulus
and many others engaged in periodic
genocidal behavior now it's true that
typically an agrarian empires and
kingdoms
there were genocide was fairly rare
simply because a lot of the wars that
took place were for control of resources
and the key resource was the peasants
you didn't want to kill all of them you
might want to kill all of the
nobles or the ruling dynasties but if
you killed all the peasants you might
not have any taxable subjects left the
mongols when they began to conquer
large parts of central of highly
civilized agricultural central asia and
china
were in the habit of killing
huge numbers of people and sometimes
emptying areas so they could turn them
into pasture land
and then the their
synthesized advisors told them well why
don't you keep some of these people and
tax them instead and once they did that
they started using killing much more
selectively as a tactic to scare people
but
so yes in agrarian societies it was
fairly unusual for these kinds of
massive deaths to take place
if we look at pre-modern genocidal
episodes
what common traits do they share the
motives could be a combination of
ecological stress
simple greed
just to take land
desire for revenge
and also and this is something that's
i have to admit i don't quite understand
but it was clearly important in the past
and it remains important in the present
a desire to be free of pollution
that combination of historical vengeance
and wish to rid the land of religiously
polluting people
is very clearly evident in biblical
calls to genocide
it's also
evident in what the crusaders did when
as they in the first crusade
began to move eastward started killing
large numbers of jews and then muslims
when they reached
muslim areas
they didn't continue doing that because
once the crusaders actually
took
the holy land they were rather few of
them and they needed the people who were
there also to cultivate and
land foremost targets
may have been couched in
pseudo-scientific
darwinian terms
but it takes only a very shallow reading
of mein kampf to see that behind the
darwinian terminology there's an
overwhelming fear of pollution
and that's something that's not easy to
explain but it was very real
aside from the scale of 20th century
genocides then there's nothing all that
new about
or all that modern about genocides as
such
now further insight into this problem
is gained by observing that while
genocide against whole peoples
or even whole tribes
or cities
though it occurred was relatively rare
in agrarian states the killing of whole
families as part of the competition
between elites for a throne or a piece
of land was anything but rare from the
english war of the roses to the chinese
to chinese imperial history
trying to kill every last member
who might have some claim to the throne
every last member of her rival family
was not rare at all and their great
histories their great stories that fill
the annals of chinese imperial history
or
or of european history or over any other
or byzantine history or ottoman history
of wanting to just get every last one
including every last baby for the simple
reason that if one survived if one baby
particularly if one male baby survived
that
male baby might grow up and be a
claimant to the throne and those kinds
of killings we don't usually label as
genocide but the idea that you you
should
to save yourself a lot of trouble in the
future
exterminate a whole family that that was
not rare at all it was the common stuff
of history in those societies
as for killings motivated by revenge
for justice or to overcome dishonor
those have always been commonplace
particularly in societies without states
able to impose justice
and such feuds often extend to
non-combatant women
and children of a whole enemy clan or
village
so
what characterizes more modern
and larger scale genocides is in a sense
simply a transformation
the transferal of individual
family
or clan deadly conflicts
to a whole
ethnicity
or a whole nation
it's not new to think that the children
of an enemy clan village
or even at the limit tribe will carry on
their father's vendettas
[Applause]
people in west virginia and albania were
doing that not all that long ago
i guess in albania they're doing it
again i don't think they're doing it in
west virginia but i'm not sure
what really changed was that family
village clan and tribe became ethnicity
and much more recently
nation
today the nation is the primary source
of our political identification
and the community most responsible for
our protection
our source of legitimate justice and our
provider of economic opportunity
those frustrated by the nation because
they're identified as a foreign ethnic
or religious group have little choice
often
but to seek to create their own nation
in order to protect themselves and
therefore they present
a menace
to existing states
in a sense what modern nationalism is
all about is a re-tribalization
it would be really better to say but
the word doesn't fit very well that it's
brought us back to the age of the clan
plant reclainization doesn't sound right
so re-tribalization
but on in really on an incomparably
larger scale
no longer is it true as in most agrarian
societies as it was
in the ottoman empire for most of its
history until the late 19th century or
for the russian empire for most of its
history until the late 19th century or
for the habsburg empire for most of its
history again until the late 19th
century
no longer is it true that most people
don't take part in politics and that
only an elite does so that if there's a
danger it's really only at the elite
level now everyone is mobilized
the peasant masses are no longer
irrelevant
as in pre-state small societies
once again
and you remember i talked about these
people in highland new guinea there also
everyone was involved in politics but
that was the village that was
a few dozen 100 people a couple of
hundred people
maybe a thousand people at most
what's happened is that we've gone back
to that away from the agrarian
stage when
only small elites were involved in
politics
and we're again in that situation where
genocide at least of your neighbors if
not on ethnic grounds was rather more
common except that today instead of the
village in the clan it's ethnicity now
all it takes then to create a potential
for genocide is a war to the death
between groups for control of the state
or between nations
then entire large populations are
involved not just little groups
it isn't necessary to have recourse to a
psychology of abnormality to explain
what's after all been when seen in these
terms fairly common though on a much
smaller scale in the past
of course it's not just ethnicity that
determines lines of conflict over state
control religion may do that or economic
class but kinship
real or imagined
is by far the most powerful binding
force of all and always has been and
when it's extended to such large groups
the results can be deadly
when control over something is vital
as the modern state is
is in question
and whole populations are seen
as the political actors
we're in the same situation as those
royal clans that once exterminated each
other
in struggles over control of the throne
genocide is obviously not the only
solution but it's certainly a possible
and common one
mass killing of an enemy group requires
viewing that group as a whole not as a
set of differentiated individuals
and that means that all people in the
ethnically religiously or nationally
defined groups are then considered as an
indivisible family
with a common worldview and common
interests
all jews are alike all tutsis are alike
all armenians are alike are all
albanians or serbs or germans they're
all alike
and therefore
they're subject to the kinds of
treatment
and punishment in extreme cases that an
individual family might have been in the
past
the individual is seen both by outsiders
and insiders as subordinated to
and defined by the group and that group
is hereditarily determined
and in that case when they whoever they
may be are seen as deeply threatening
when the competition for resources
becomes desperate when a sense of
victimization becomes overwhelming then
all of them
whoever they may be are the deadly enemy
all of this existed before modern
nationalism bought on a lesser scale
now clearly if this explains why
genocide has come to occur in a much
larger scale than before and why
ethnonationalism is today an important
phenomenon it still doesn't tell us
it
it sort of tells us but doesn't really
tell us under what conditions it becomes
so severe that these mass killings
actually take place
in the past there were many kinds of
circumstances that could alleviate the
deadliness of the conflict
between neighboring tribes or within
between clans or between competing
families they could partition a
territory or they could intermarry and
the wheat could assimilate with a strong
or one group could migrate
and now when there's ethnic conflict the
same solutions are also available
but now as in the past
both sides have to see the conflict as
less than deadly
for those kinds of more beneficial
or less deadly outcomes to occur
the great ethno-political
tragedies of east central europe in the
20th century have been and continue to
be the product
of retribalized national entities in
which the state was seized by people who
believed that their own group was in
mortal peril unless it rid itself
entirely of deadly enemy tribes
and that's what's going on in serbia
once that happened whether the
perception was somewhat
even if hardly entirely correct as in
the case of the ottoman fears about
armenian nationalists
or if that perception was entirely
imagined and unreal
as in the case of the nazis perception
about the jews the results were
catastrophic
and here i want to say something
in parentheses i didn't have this
written down in my talk but
i
i get a little sick hearing constantly
that slobodan milosevic is just an
opportunist and doesn't believe in what
he's doing
i have no doubt that he's an opportunist
and i have no doubt that he's not a nice
man and i have no doubt that he's
committing atrocities and hopes to hang
on to power but there were lots of other
ways of doing it why is it that we
constantly think that just because our
perception of an ethnic conflict
would indicate to us that
the enemy of this group are not really
all that dangerous as certainly would be
the case of our perception of the
situation of the jews in germany no re
or in europe as a whole no no realistic
modern historian can think that the jews
really threatened germany at that time
nevertheless the perception of threat on
the part of the nazis of the top nazi
leadership not all the nazis some of
them were opportunists but on the part
of hitler and himmler and a lot of
others was that this was an absolutely
deadly menace and the perception on the
part of a great many serbian
intellectuals today and of a great many
serbians was that all the ethnic the
ethnicities around them that they've
been treating so badly are a deadly
menace to them and i don't think it's
unbelievable that slobodan milosevic
agrees with that to some extent to some
considerable extent
well we know that when
spontaneous popular ethnic violence
breaks out
death rates tend to actually be rather
low a lot of these lower down cases have
seen
quite a bit of very low level
spontaneous violence
the fact is that the large scale
killings that have occurred in the 20th
century have all taken place and that
goes for the large-scale
ethnic cleansings have all taken place
when the state itself and its whole
apparatus was seized by a group of
leaders who identified
other ethnicities as their main and
extremely deadly problem
as the ottoman leadership did toward the
armenians as the german nazis did toward
the jews as the
certainly
serbians
good portion of those in charge in
serbia see
the albanians today and have seen some
other groups including the croats and as
the croatian leadership under franja
tuchman also saw the serbs as a deadly
threat and it's this perception of
threat that's the key
even in cases of extreme tension
spontaneous outbursts of ethnic violence
if the leadership of the state is not
involved quickly die out
it's only when the state brings its full
force to bear that then you get the full
retribalization and that's another
reason why in the 20th century
cases have been relatively rare of
genocide but when they've occurred
they've been massive because you take
into consideration the great power of
modern states
and what large populations they include
then you get the result that i'm talking
about
you can look at a lot of cases where
there's ethnic tension and where the
state has not been controlled by people
who are in a state of panic and there
you don't see that kind of large-scale
killing one reason that there isn't
going to be at least and there hasn't
been in the 1990s there could have been
but there hasn't been in the 1990s and
there won't be at least
in the immediate foreseeable future
large-scale killing of hungarians in
romania is because for various reasons
the romanian state is not in control of
people who think that the hungarian
situation is worth panicking about yes
it's a problem but they don't think
they're going to be destroyed by the
hungarians
a very obvious case the one that's
not in east central europe but is very
much in europe is the case of northern
ireland
i was in northern ireland last year
and the hatred between protestants and
catholics is is old it's actually quite
a bit older than
most of the hatreds that are today
called old in the balkans
that is to say it really goes back to
the late 17th century you can you can
really trace what happened in the 17th
and 18th century so it's not ancient
ancient it's not as ancient as some
nationalist historians irish historians
would have it but it's pretty old and
it's very real and it's
quite deep and there never was any
possibility of the genocide of the
protestants trying to kill all the
catholics
and the reason for that is because the
state in charge happened to be
the united kingdom and for them it's a
fair it's not an important issue
i don't mean to belittle it but
the people who control the government in
london don't think that whatever happens
to northern ireland is going to deeply
affect them one way or the other and so
as rulers of that particular state with
the military and police apparatus they
simply don't allow mass killing to occur
and so there is killing there have been
several thousand people killed but it
doesn't go to the extent that it did
when panicked leaders take control of
the state
that's why the czechoslovak breakup was
so peaceful there was hardly anyone and
certainly not the political economic or
intellectual elites of those
either of those nations who felt
particularly threatened uh by the other
and there were antagonistic sentiments
certainly but not desperate fear
well invaders dealing with people they
consider entirely foreign may kill
without remorse or just out of greed but
people who have lived next to each other
and intermingled for a long time
need more than just that to kill each
other
they need a sense of panic
and in most of the very mixed
populations of east central europe in
the mid 19th century that kind of panic
was missing
but in the late 19th century in the
20th century it occurred after the
balkan wars after world war one
after the
change in boundaries that left certain
elites with nothing
after the great depression
a sense of panic was much more
widespread as people saw the
consequences of having one ethnicity or
another take control of the state
and as a result of world war ii it
became that much more widespread
you all know i'm sure
that the place where the history of mass
killing in yugoslavia really started was
during world war ii
there were some people killed in the
1930s very few there were tensions no
doubt there were tensions very severe
tensions but the mass killings not
something that happened back in the
middle ages they happened during world
war ii and that isn't such a long time
ago
of course they're always
what are called
ethnic entrepreneurs around people like
slobodan milosevic or franio tujman to
exacerbate and use this growing panic
but it's only when they have enough
followers around who also share their
sense of panic that they can take over
state
and then
the real trouble starts
that's when insecurity and fright come
into play and produce climates in which
states turn into killing machines
particular leaders
their ideologies and fears explain how
ethnic tensions turn into mass
expulsions and killings
but ethnic tension itself
prior to the catastrophe is a function
of something far deeper
and to counter it takes strategies far
more complex than just picking new
leaders
to counter take strategies to avoid
tension from becoming panic
and great fear
whether for realistic or unrealistic
reasons
now to conclude
of all of the possible lessons to be
learned from the experience of east
central europe
about modern ethnic conflict
i want to stress just one
don't think that this part of the world
east central europe is in any sense
uniquely evil
primitive
or uniquely cursed by its historical
legacy
it sounds good to say that
it's exotic
it moves the blame it shifts the blame
from current actors
or from us for not doing anything to
some
dim historical force oh well this place
is unique they've always been killing
each other there's nothing we can do
about it
don't think that that's so there's
nothing unique about this region and
there's no guarantee that this sort of
thing can happen elsewhere it has
happened elsewhere
the process at work the mass
re-tribalization of the world's
population is a process that began only
a short time ago in historical terms
it's mostly a 19th and 20th century
phenomenon
and there's no guarantee that it's a
process that's either being reversed
or one that's been completed in all of
the places that are now for the time
being quiet
most of us who are old enough and who
were so-called experts in this area
thought that in yugoslavia by 1970
it was pretty much all over yes i mean
we knew there was there were tensions
and so on
but i don't recall a single expert in
1970
thinking that the yugoslav state wasn't
there for good
tito had done all these wonderful things
there were lots of reasons
to say that it was over and it obviously
wasn't
we know
that we were wrong
all it took was a period of generalized
social distress and panic
that allowed some ethnic entrepreneurs
to come to the fore and it all came
apart
now since we continue
even to some extent in the united states
to re-tribalize ourselves
the potential for the kinds of disasters
which have happened in east central
europe exist elsewhere
it's almost certain
that there'll be a whole new range of
terrible ethnic conflicts activated in
the 21st century
some of them
will be lower down in the scale
some of them
will move up and produce new and as yet
unexpected genocides and massive
expulsions
it wouldn't be possible to try to
predict
where
any of these might take place
or if it would be that's the subject for
at least one or two or three more talks
so with that i'll stop and see if you
have any questions thank you
writers now ranking ethnic conflicts
around the world saying that and this is
very common it's only certain cases that
tend to boil over into something really
bad i mean what about like warning
signals and things that like people
should be looking for more i mean
professor king always says we have to
really look at this more um
systematically it's not like things just
happen i mean things happen for a reason
i mean what are some of the um i guess
ways people are uh things people are
coming up with so that they can you know
predict this stuff better and then deal
with it better when it happens instead
of just you know running around with not
knowing what's going on
the best one is
a growing perception in the intellectual
and political
and social elite of a place that their
tribe is under deadly attack
and a sense of panic that allows
the people that
are called ethnic entrepreneurs to come
to the fore i mean we have ethnic
entrepreneurs in this country al
sharpton
is a great ethnic entrepreneur
uh he's not going to take power
and he's not even going to become the
main spokesman of the african-american
community in this country
though he might if there were a sense of
absolute panic
in a sense that they're about to kill us
all
then those kinds of leaders come to the
fore or they're about to take everything
away from us
in yugoslavia
absolutely
the experts by the mid-1980s knew that
something terrible was happening
they didn't in 1970 and you can trace
the growth of a sense of panic has to do
with the failure of the communist
economy the growing inflation in the 80s
and the fact that the arrangement that
had been made before was was
really in a way unforeseen by tito one
that
not only
used old tribal boundaries and i think
the term tribe is appropriate i mean it
used all tribal boundaries but
tribalized people who hadn't been
tribalized before that is to say
benefits were distributed on the basis
of region which was tied to ethnicity so
that all politics took place in that
framework and in those conditions then
in a situation of panic
then these ethnic entrepreneurs can take
power and we can we can
we can spot those people by reading what
they write i could tell you
or professor king could tell you since
he's
a better specialist than i am who such
people are in romania i mean we there
are such people around in the last
election they did very poorly
romania is doing poorly in general but
there isn't a sense of panic that
the hungarians are going to get it all
and we're going to lose everything we
romanians or the jews are going to get
it all and we're going to lose
everything or the bulgarians
to the south are going to get it all or
anything like that but we we can
actually see when such a development
starts taking place and in the most
extreme cases
not counting
the herrero in 1905 germany was in no
sense threatened by the herrera but in
the case of the armenians
the nazi perception of the jews because
the nazi perception of the jews was
not that it was just
jews in germany but that the whole
bolshevik menace was jewish
hitler
frequently said it's too bad that stalin
is surrounded by and run by jews which
was not true at all there was only as
far as i know one jew left in the
politburo
by that time and that was kaganovich and
all the others all the other top ones
had been purged and killed and hit
stalin himself was actually turns out
quite an anti-semite but the point is
hitler had this sense that the whole
soviet union was a vast jewish
conspiracy so there was a sense of panic
i put cambodia there
i didn't explain it it really isn't the
area that we're talking about but there
was a very strong ethnic element that is
very well known by the experts but not
so well known by the general press and
that was this consuming fear that the
vietnamese were about to obliterate the
khmer race and it was widespread in
throughout the cambodian elite the
communists and the non-communists and
the killing started with the killing of
vietnamese
and ben kiernan a professor history
professor yale who was the best
specialist on this says that he thinks
it may be the only case
of these well-known cases when you speak
just at the vietnamese where every
everyone was killed a lot of vietnamese
fled when the khmer rouge took power but
of those who are left he has never been
able to find one who survived
and there was this sense of panic as a
matter of fact
the foreign minister who is still
at large i mean he's known where he is
but he hasn't been put up for trial he
was one of the leaders of the khmer
rouge one of the surviving ones what
said at a press conference after
the khmer rouge were overthrown why did
you kill so many cambodians he said we
didn't kill many cambodians a few
thousand i mean the generally accepted
number is over a million and the best
demographers recently who have studied
this think it might have been two
million which is a higher than previous
estimate kirsanpan said we only killed
the two or three thousand
and
he was giving a press conference since
he has had a phd in sociology from the
university of paris he's very polished
and knows what he's talking about and he
was asked well
well what about all those other people
who died and he said oh well though they
were vietnamese
or
cambodians with vietnamese minds there
was this deadly fear of infection of
vietnamese thinking so
you could see that coming actually if
you read what these people were saying
and that's what we can do so it's that
combination
that's the best we can do
as scholars but yes we can tell i have
to tell you one anecdote about
a yugoslav a serb
who was a fairly well-known philosopher
certainly
who was a member of the praxis group
which was a liberal marxist group and
who lectured in the united states and
even had a part-time appointment in the
united states and he told me
in
1990
when i last saw him
before he became an ultra serbian
nationalist and a defender of the
serbian cause which is remained to this
day
he said to me oh it isn't as serious as
what the press is saying and i said you
mean the press is making it all up
because by 1990 things were pretty bad
he said no no no all these things are
really taking place but everybody knows
that if we break up it'll be a
catastrophe there'll be thousands of
deaths the economy will be so we won't
do it and he was almost right everybody
by that time did know but by that time
the sense of panic and actually his own
i could tell
interspersed with his conversations was
why is everybody picking on the serbs
and i haven't spoken to him in the last
month
but i'm sure that that sense of
fear of the outside is that much
stronger and it's not something that's
calculated to
in what's happening now it's not
calculated to make that sense of fear
any easier it justifies for people there
however evil they may be and there's no
doubt that what the serbs are doing is
evil it justifies for them the growing
perception they've had for the last 15
20 years that everyone is out to get
them and that the world treats them
unfairly and that's
and
that's what this whole
that's been since the 19th century this
whole myth of kosovo and all that is is
all about victimization that that's a
really good indicator that something is
going seriously wrong when a large
number of people particularly at the
elite level feel a dreadful sense of
victimization
so
yeah yes i wanted to know if you saw the
um interview on 60 minutes of mrs
milosevic
and her perception of what was happening
in kosovo
i guess she's a professor at the
university of belgrade in marx's
democracism or she was yeah and um
i also wanted to ask you about when
excuse me when you um
no of war criminals such as kardash who
is a psychiatrist and from what i was
told taught psychiatry
at the university of belgrade who
perhaps
maybe was an architect of of some of
what's been going on or certainly was
recently
yeah
and arkhan and
and and
these people were never arrested and and
then when arkhan was actually seen
leaving
a burning kosovar village with the many
serbs
on bbc
and then was interviewed by matt lauer
onto today's show and on some other show
and they asked him are you a war
criminal and he said well i mean he just
didn't take it very seriously
and
i mean when do we take it seriously
after two two million people are uh
slotted or when do we arrest these
people and actually use
the type of force you that you would use
when you're when somebody has been is
held as a hostage you know take take
these people as if they're hostages or
well
you're there's several parts of your
question one one of which i can't begin
to answer and that is the question of
when we presumably here in the united
states do something
because
it's rather unpredictable when
we do something no one did anything
about the nazis until it was much too
late
our president
officially declared that what was going
on in rwanda in 1994
when by the way more people were killed
than have been killed in kosovo
and
probably in bosnia combined the general
estimate in bosnia is about 200 000 dead
maybe more but it's 800 000 in ronda our
president said that's not a genocide and
the reason he said that was to avoid
committing american troops because we've
signed a convention that says that the
united nations should intervene in the
case of genocide
and there's a disgraceful i mean a truly
disgraceful record by the secretary
president secretary general of the
united nations kofi annan who was
responsible for that part of the world
and that issue at that time who simply
pretended and still claims he never saw
the documents the un field
representatives
said what was coming it was well known
what was coming
and he said no so
since i'm not in a position of power
and i don't understand american politics
very well i can't tell you anything
about
when we do intervene
and what cases we leave alone in what
cases we don't
another part of your question i can say
something about i don't think arkhan is
an intellectual but some of the people
involved like mrs milosevic
and by the way her husband's slobodan
milosevic is a very bright man his
english is pretty good he knows some
other languages he was a well-trained
banker
uh i don't know if he qualifies as
an intellectual but he's certainly part
of the educated elite and yes kaio-jich
was a psychiatrist and so on it's a
really big mistake to think that these
kinds of things are done by
for the ugly masses down below
no serious historian would believe this
about the nazis but it is part of
popular perception that they were all
out of the gutter well sure they found
people
to do some of the actual killing who
were but the the people in charge were
not
uh a lot of them were well educated
there was a an a e show
about the einsatzgruppen recently
uh that did very extensive interviewing
of people who tried them and showed all
movies and so on
and this it
used some of the work of the historian
christopher browning who shows that the
leadership of the main units was
it was part of the german elite i mean
they were they were professors who
became colonels and so on and uh and yes
when when they actually got to the
killing in some cases they would hire
sort of local ukrainian tufts you know
to do some of the killing but that isn't
where it came from so and that's very
much a part of what i said that the
state has to take control and why i
think that the thinking of the elite is
one of the great tip-offs of what's
going on
and a sense that
that their
group is being victimized and they begin
to see it as their responsibility
to save their group and they begin to
see the only possible solution as mass
extermination the same was true of the
khmer rouge leadership the same with was
true of the young turks
uh they weren't all so young by then
anymore but the the party called the
young turks who was in control of the
ottoman empire these weren't peasants
these were well-educated people who who
spoke western languages they some of
them spoke german some of them spoke
french who were sophisticated and who
saw the world in in a rather large way
and that's what's required in order to
have this mass re-tribalization because
after all it's a fairly abstract concept
any one of us could understand that if
we're in a fight to the death with our
neighbors over control of a piece of
property and if they get it we start to
death and if we get it they starve to
death then we have to kill them but
conceptualizing of whole nations which
consist of people we've never met
and and even those who are in in our
nation
even in the most ethnically oriented
nation where there's an assumption of
kinship that's a fairly abstract concept
since we don't know most of these people
it takes
some serious thinking to
turn the situation into that kind of
deadly tribal conflict so the elites are
very important
and when do we do something about them
well
it would be nice if we could but
believe me
you know this already
even if scholarship were much better
than it is
we still wouldn't be listened to
and certainly in this
in the most recent balkan crisis
i don't know a single
prominent specialist the balkans who
thinks that we're doing it right i know
many who think that it's right for us to
do something
but
it doesn't seem as if anyone who really
knew the situation was listened to
the consequences of what we're doing
however right we may be morally not
everyone agrees that we're right morally
but many do i do
think that we're right morally
but as you know
however right morally we may be
we haven't prevented
the killing of tens of thousands in the
expulsion of hundreds of thousands so
and a lot and by this point a lot of
experts really did know that this was
going to happen if we conducted the kind
of military campaign we've conducted
so i can't tell you how
how we can make justice more effective
on an international scale
yes
i'm a scholar from costa rica journalist
uh i studied here at georgetown
university and uh i have a one remark
and uh one question the remark is that i
don't like that czechoslovakia is like
such something like a positive example
for solving the problem uh i must tell
you that uh
in our country 60 percent of inhabitants
in of both sides czech and slovak
republic uh
didn't want to have this divorce so and
the politicians didn't ask us so we
didn't have war but we don't have a
country i was born in chicago slovakia
but czechoslovakia doesn't exist anymore
so i'm not so happy about it i know that
west is happy about it that there was no
war but i am not
so uh
and the second uh the question is uh do
you think that uh
the people the today war criminals uh uh
can be such criminal also because the
war criminals of uh the past
wasn't punished uh my opinion after
after 48 1948 there were there was no
uh no no punishment of uh war criminals
uh no punishment of soviet leaders who
had invited uh invaded uh into
czechoslovakia no punishment of
communists
who
made some coverties and also today there
is no punishment and nobody thinks about
the punishment of slobodan milosevic for
the things which he is which
he is doing so do you think that it is
not also a mistake which uh avoid to
bring more justice in the international
cases
well uh on the first part of your
question i'm aware of the fact that the
the split occurred because of netjar and
vatsav klaus
uh and particularly vatsev klaus saw an
opportunity to get rid of a part of the
country he didn't want
and
he pulled it off
and however unfortunate it may be
i didn't mean to praise it so much as to
say
that if somehow yugoslavia had worked
out like that
it would have been better for the
yugoslavs that is to say
whatever the cause it was peaceful and
so that's why
we in the west tend to look at that case
and say
well maybe it's unfortunate but this is
not a tragedy on the level of some of
the others
now on the punishment of war criminals
they're two different issues
one of them is international
and that's that's really an answer to
your question i said i just can't answer
uh
we don't have an international state
so we don't have a mechanism for
punishing
no no but i mean we have an
international tribunal but everyone has
to agree you know uh
and uh
if we can find some russian who
committed some atrocity in afghanistan
and the russians don't want to give him
up they're not going to give him up it's
taken what
a decade to get two people out of libya
and libya is a tiny country i mean in
population and it finally sent two
people and we know perfectly well even
in that case
that if these two libyans who have just
been sent up to the court in the hague
actually planned this it was because
muammar gaddafi told them to it's pretty
unlikely that two members of the
libyan security forces bombed the plane
just for the hell of it uh without
and in fact that story is more
complicated than that because the
syrians were almost certainly involved
but we don't want to involve the syrians
publicly because our relations with them
are too important because of other
reasons
and that that brings up any one of these
cases that you look at i mean we don't
have an international system and then
countries behave then in the sense the
same sense that
that feuding families did in places
where there were no states
pre-state societies
had these long lasting feuds that was
the only system of justice
and
there was no there is no international
police force maybe we should have one
whether we will have one or not i can't
say but in any case there isn't one and
and so that's that's the problem
milosevic
i'm not privy to our president's
thinking i'm sure if he could get some
deal with milosevic now that would let
him back out
with any grace at all
he would be more than happy to give
milosevic a promise that will never
bother him
and in fact that might be
a solution and that brings me to the
second part of this which is
of your question
which is internal punishment of work of
criminals
and here
a most interesting case well there were
interesting cases in world war ii after
world war ii rather few nazis were
executed as you know
there were
very few japanese somewhat larger number
of germans but not very many
uh some of the most prominent ones and
then it continued some of the leaders of
the einstein's gloop and for example
some of the heads of concentration camps
were
but a tiny number compared to the total
number of nazis a contemporary case is
south africa and the whole truth and
reconciliation committee
and that there's a lot of writing about
that there's some good south african
psychologists who've been studying this
what are you supposed to do
we know that terrible things were done
by the apartheid regime
they came from the top but it went down
quite far
not every white south african was
responsible
but in the police
and the army a lot were and among police
officers a lot more responsible
if all of them are prosecuted
the white population there will panic
now in this case what that means
is not that
they'll overthrow the state and
try to wipe out
the black population they're not in no
position to do that in that case all it
means is they'll leave
and the government doesn't want that
because the economic consequences for
south africa would be catastrophic and
so they're desperately struggling
with a formula that sort of lets them
off the hook and that formula is if
you're willing to confess
and say you're sorry then you're let off
as long as you can make a case that was
a political act
obviously if it was a purely criminal
act in the
very strict sense of the case that's
less easy but there's a lot of anger
among the relatives of a lot of people
who were tortured and killed because
there were
probably a few thousand deaths uh and
there and there was torture and
there's a lot of anger because you get
these cases of white policemen and and
some blacks as well by the way because
the there were a lot of black policemen
and it was a very complicated system but
of people getting up and saying yes i
tortured such and such
yeah i'm sorry and then he walks off
and the surviving parents or wives or
children are furious they say this man
has just admitted that he tortured
someone that he committed this criminal
act
well
why aren't they being
prosecuted
so
it's touch in that respect and also you
know that with germany after world war
ii
there were
several reasons why the prosecution
stopped one of which was to get germany
let germany get back on its feet if
every nazi had been prosecuted germany
couldn't function
it wasn't just in germany
i was born in france during the war and
so i grew up here knowing something
about what was going on at that time i
wasn't involved obviously i'm
not quite that old but but my parents
were of that generation who knew what
was going on
and
there was this myth that was created in
france that only a few bad frenchmen
collaborated with the germans that myth
has been exploded many many times since
then but only a few decades later i mean
there was the sorrow in the pity which
was the movie that was sort of the first
indication of this and now there's lots
of scholarship
but
and the scholarship now shows that a lot
of frenchmen were were involved uh and
many committed to
what could be considered crimes well the
fact is that that was known at the time
and that was not a great mystery in 1944
and 1945
but a decision was made
one of those who made that decision was
to go
and there were some others people on the
left
even people who had suffered during the
war that if they really went after
all those who were responsible france
couldn't function
so what do you do
i mean you come back even when it's an
internal problem and there is a system
of of justice that has the force to be
applied we could have done it to the to
the nazis because we really control
germany the french
who took power
in 44 when france was liberated could
have gone after every nazi
it's not certain what france would be
like today but it wouldn't have gotten
back on its feet so quickly so where do
you draw the line and that's not a
question i can answer but it's a very
serious question
and it has something to do with why even
internationally we're loath to go after
certain people because
that makes the possibilities of
reconciliation
that much harder
in in the law
i'm not a legal specialist but in
sociology as well there's a sociology of
the law there's this great effort to say
that justice and revenge are not the
same thing
and of course there's certain areas of
the law that have nothing to do with
revenge
bankruptcy law and so on
but when it comes to criminal law as the
french sociologist daniel durkheim said
justice is revenge
and revenge is one of those things that
keeps a conflict going
and makes reconciliation that much more
difficult
that was a long way of saying i don't
have an answer to the second part either
so yeah and then i'll go to you but
very wide-ranging analysis but as a
political scientist i was most
fascinated with your political points
for example i heard you say that once a
group takes over a state and the
paranoid group becomes dominant that's a
crucial point you mentioned the totalist
ideologies national socialism communism
khmer rouge
and i would add to that you also
mentioned that total war at the end of
world war ii even the western allies
agreed that the germans could be evicted
in a very you know genocidal way
actually from eastern europe so to
summarize all of that doesn't it sound
that democracy or non-total or
non-ideological systems would be one
recipe for better
arrangements even when you mention the
herrera the social democrats were
crucial in limiting that genocide so in
my analysis actually democratic systems
are a major counterpart yes that that's
that's on the whole very true
also democratic systems
uh
on the whole tend to individualize
people more
and
uh one of the characteristics of
american politics is that people
switch sides they change class they
change party alliances party
alliances aren't all that firm and that
makes a lot of compromises more possible
and it makes it more difficult to
totalize an enemy however democracy is
no sure
solution because in croatian in serbia
milosevic and tujman really were elected
there was some cheating but they really
were pretty popular
and that indicates that a substantial
portion of the whole population first of
all viewed others
in a tribal sense and secondly were
panicked
when democratic majorities become
panicked or or as in the case of germany
a very substantial democratic minorities
weimar was a democracy and hitler was
elected i mean there was parliamentary
maneuvering he didn't his party didn't
get a majority but in the first election
in 32 they got 40 some percent in the
second election somewhat less and in
combination with the other far-right
parties there was a democratic process
until he got power then he
squeezed it off
and there's been a lot of analysis uh
obviously of of who voted for hitler
there is a
book by a recent book by sociologist
named william brusting and there have
been a lot of books there's an older
book by a political scientist named
hamilton who voted for hitler
and it's very clear that a lot of people
who voted for hitler didn't realize that
what was going to come eventually was
the extermination of the jews however
anti-semitic germany may have been they
weren't all that many people who really
could have faced what was coming
what is evident however is that there
was a sense of panic that had developed
in germany that a lot of germans didn't
know why but there had been a series of
catastrophes right there had been world
war one i mean there'd been this strong
imperial
german ideal imperial in the sense that
it was the german empire
you worked hard and you saved and and
you could you could have a prosperous
life you lived in a nation that was
powerful and and growing uh with a sound
economy and a sound currency and then
everything fell apart you know the story
of world war one
to many germans it seemed as it fell
apart in the last few weeks because they
didn't know how bad the situation was
then there was the inflation of 1923
then there was the great depression and
the whole world of a lot of people was
just thrown upside down
interestingly enough the two
substantial groups in germany who had
not been part of the imperial consensus
namely a large portion of the catholics
and the working class never voted for
the nazis
the catholic center party kept its
strength and though within the left the
social democrats lost that was gained by
the communists
the working class left as a whole
remained as strong and didn't fall for
this because they were not as shaken
because they never completely believed
in the imperial consensus either
but many germans did if you take out the
catholics and the
and the working-class left
parties then an overwhelming majority of
the rest of the germans voted for the
nazis
or for their allies and so democracy is
not a guarantee but it's it's a big help
but
there's nothing to say that if we had 25
years
of
catastrophe here
we might not be facing
some
roughly analogous situation we've never
had 25 years of catastrophe the closest
we came was the depression
we had 10 years of bad economic times
but it was not accompanied by by
political collapse it was not
accompanied by
any national humiliation
and it was not accompanied by any
visible threat of any sort from the
outside
so
we didn't react nearly as badly but yes
democracy helped but it's not not the
only answer
okay all right you i think you had a
question
social and cross-cultural psychology
and even outlining here basically
addressing the question
in ethnic conflicts what is it that
causes these mass killings what's what
is that and you've identified a factor
of social panic
and this pervasive fear and particularly
deadly fear um yet it occurred to me
that in identifying the fact that
ukrainians were brought in to actually
in the
in germany were actually brought in to
do the killings and for example in
addressing the you know the question
that well actually most germans probably
weren't really ready to
kill all of the jews even though they
you know
went through this democratic process
that
by ex simply by suggesting this factor
that there's a social panic you haven't
yet explained the ability of the
the person
to
murder to participate in mass murders i
mean the ukrainians didn't have a few
they weren't the ones that are you know
brought in they weren't they weren't you
know
uh they didn't have this this fear
and it
that suggests that that also doesn't
explain why the people who were in the
country are participating whatever
country you you know may use are
participating in the mass killings yes
there's this pervasive sense of fear and
dread but what is it that actually
brings the individual to be able to
participate in mass murder okay yeah all
right
uh
that that's a that's a very good last
question
do i have another hour
uh
they're two different levels they're
actually several different levels with
respect to the nazi killings christopher
browning is the best historian he's very
good and he has used psychology
um i mean he used the milgram experiment
and but i don't know if you've ever seen
his book ordinary men
but it's it's very good he tries he
analyzes the documents
of these and he's he's writing more
because that's what he's he's devoted
his whole life to just uncovering
documents of people who are involved in
the killing
the killing by the einsatzgruppen
was by no means primarily done by
ukrainians or lithuanians
some of those groups
and that's not the einsatzgruppen as
such but later the ordinary men is not
about the inside scoop and it's about
a police battalion a reserve police
battalion in poland
that consisted of
men who were told to be on the front
they're in their 30s
which is not prime soldier material
and
there there was
there's a whole file of one particular
police battalion and by daniel goldhagen
used this
the same
information
to come to somewhat different conclusion
but
there was the butcher the baker the
candlestick maker and the professor
in that and what um
what the people have looked at that
archive found which are letters sent
home somehow all wound up in one bundle
somewhere
they were collected and because in their
records of them
that
very few
started this
with any enthusiasm
after the first killing a lot of them
threw up
most of them got used to it
a few
liked it from the beginning
the i don't know that there's any way of
saying that any particular culture is
more sadistic than any other but in any
culture including ours
they're enough people who actually like
this sort of thing so that if you start
systematically rounding them up to do it
you'll find people to do it
that doesn't explain very much because
people like that even the most sadistic
and brutal if they act on their own
we've had mass killers you know remember
jeffrey darman you know cut up people
and put them in his refrigerator those
kind of people don't come to power
they're crazy
but you can always find people who are
either that bad or
sadist but under control
unless they're told by the government
what you're doing is good then you'll
get quite a few
i don't think that it's that hard to
explain that
what christopher browning and others
have found was that some of the people
in these killing battalions never got
used to it
there's a story in there of one of the
officers who every time they went out to
kill
said he was sick and stayed in bed and
he just never did it
there were others who actually
said they would not do it
and they were just sent off to some
other part of the army
uh no one got into trouble among the
nazis
for being unwilling to kill
jews they did if they
tried to publicize it and to tell the
other officers hey we've got to stop
this then they did get into trouble but
those who said no this just sickens me i
just don't want to do it they were just
sent off
so
if there hadn't been a core of real
believers behind this in charge of the
state it wouldn't have happened
and that's why i think that
that daniel goldhagen's argument is a
little too simplistic
yes there was a pervasive anti-semitism
in germany yes there were some germans
who really did think that the jews were
a racial threat and who wanted to
exterminate them but what it really took
was for that group to get into power
once they did
then we know and that's why states are
so dangerous we know that most people
will follow along when they're drafted
into the army
and we know that they are everywhere
some sadists and some people who enjoy
it and it's very remarkable i mean
in the letters that went home
there was german military censorship but
they couldn't censor everything and some
of the people involved
didn't realize exactly what they were
saying they actually wrote descriptions
of this
and they would say well this is really
disgusting i can't stand it and then but
but a few
sort of enjoyed it but the nazi high
command himmler in particular was well
aware of the fact that this was not
something that should be spread in
pictures
in newspapers
and the
the people in charge of this were under
strict orders not to talk about it in
fact many himmler speeches to
to assess people saying i know that what
you're doing is very difficult but this
we have to do this it's for history it's
to save the german people and there are
also a lot of
there's a famous speech by himmler in
which he says
we have to do this
we can't now publicly praise you for
what you're doing but future generations
will praise you
but we have to remember something
all of you all of us
have
a favorite jew someone we know and we
say we should exempt that one no
we should exempt none of them all of
them
and none of that makes sense unless
there was this fear of racial pollution
the notion that jews were a disease
there's plenty of writing
starting in
actually in the 1860s and 1870s of a
growing number of anti-semites using
that and it's that the people who
believe that
came into power that's really what
explains it
the ideology of the local fud thug i
mean that's why when you mention arkhan
who as far as i know is someone who if
he weren't
killing albanians or earlier killing
muslims he would be a gangster rubbing
out people too he's much less
interesting to me than
mrs milosevic
who uh
and
so just like with the nazis
the intellectuals who participated in
this
the colonels and generals who had high
degrees and so on uh or even hitler who
was not himself a highly educated man
but who read a lot knew a lot of history
and who thought a lot about this he
wasn't quite as much of a simpleton as
he's been made out to be
those are the people who are really
interesting how do they come to think
like that and that's a somewhat
different psychological problem than why
people follow along and that's why the
social psychological experiments of
someone like milgram why they i don't
know if you all know this but this is
someone who actually put people
through something that wouldn't be
allowed now because it would be
considered unethical he put subjects
through a procedure in which they
thought they were killing someone i'll
make it short and he found out that
depending on the circumstances if you've
got people in white coats in a lab to
take subjects and push buttons
and then have an actor there who's
who was feigning being electrocuted to
death
depending on the circumstances 25 or
more would just go through and push all
the buttons that's explaining the
followers
as far as i know there's no good social
psychological experiment they can study
the leaders because most
social psychology is done with college
students
and
you know undergraduates here so far none
of them
have gotten to positions of leadership
and
so but but there is a very interesting
psychological problem of how do you
become panicked and the general
psychology of panic is interesting
there's a psychologist named irvin staub
who's trying to work on this so anyway
thanks thanks very much dan for an
excellent talk and
maybe we can continue the conversation
and let me invite all of you just to
join us in the back for uh for a glass
of wine
thanks again
open yeah
tomorrow night on c-span america and the
courts this week it's a look at the life
and work of cass gilbert the architect
of the supreme court building
we'll see remarks by columbia university
professor